- My big thing is that people's fears
are predicated other people.
You're allowing other people's opinions
to dictate your life.
(soft music)
Letting somebody else dictate your life
is immediate unhappiness.
You're not in control.
There is nothing, nothing, more difficult
than navigating your life based
on somebody else's opinion.
You actually care about
what your dad or mom
or grandma or husband or wife or daughter
or son is gonna say about
you if you do this thing.
It doesn't matter what they think.
When you're fuckin' 92
and you're sitting there
you're not gonna give a shit about what
punkman96 had to say.
Or even what your aunt had to say,
who's miserable 'cause she never got hers
so she's trying to keep you down.
Negative people latch
on to positive people
and try to seclude them from the world
because that's their energy.
In work I see it everyday.
In life I see it everyday.
It's just what it is.
I hate how many people judge other people
without having all the context.
Every time you fuckin' judge
you make yourself vulnerable.
99.9% of the people that you
judge or have opinions on
you have no idea what the
fuck is actually happening
in their lives.
Like you don't fucking
know what's going on
in somebody's fuckin' home.
Everybody sucks at something, right?
We all have shortcomings.
And for me it's like why
don't we just audit that?
Why don't we just look at it that way?
And be like, I'm good at this,
but I'm not good at that.
Everybody's so absolute.
Are you really really really
not gonna live your life
based on somebody's anonymous
fuckin' icon feedback
that you suck, they fuckin' suck.
Go do your thing, don't listen to anybody
but what's in your fuckin'
mind and the fuckin' heart.
And not living a life where you allow
other people's judgment
to dictate your behavior.
You're letting your homie or your aunt
or somebody else shit on you.
It's going in your head and now you think
you're shitting on yourself.
You're valuing somebody
else's opinion too much.
So many of you are gonna be resentful
and blame somebody else besides yourself,
it's your fault that
you're not doing your thing
and so the reason I think it's happening
is the judgment of
others, it's the same shit
from fourth and fifth
grade that we develop.
This is very complicated,
but unbelievably simple.
You're worried about
what other people think.
You give up on that shit and you're clean.
And you can go and all of a sudden
it's not how much money you have
or how much time you have, you
just see that you can do it.
Money ain't, time ain't
shit of holding you back
compared to your worry about
other people's opinions.
Do you know what it's like
to be in your own head
and nothing else matters?
Do you know what it feels
like to give a shit so much
about what everybody
thinks yet not care at all?
Do you know that when I leave here
I'm gonna look at every
single tweet about this talk
and if somebody says, nah,
I'm gonna be devastated
like I fuckin' died, yet
equally don't give a fuck?
When you can get to that
place, amazing shit happens.
You know why?
'Cause you stop being scared.
And I want that for every fuckin' person
because let me tell you
something, it fucking is the best.
You only have one life.
And it's much better
to live it for yourself
than somebody else.
- Four hundred trillion to one.
- That's it, baby.